Murali Norris and sermon founder of Sony
Capital Corporation I'm 28 years old my
company that produces electricity it's
this our power plans based on gas and
they perceive tricity for over 1 million
people to reach a shout over 300,000
homes this for power plants are located
are in tienen were continuing to invest
in the same space being a part of
something big that's always exciting and
being part of a world that's changing
and doing meaningful things of your life
nothing that that's always a part of
what drives me every morning the good
part about being under 30 is that if you
have a good idea you focus on the
project on the numbers and the story and
you make them focus on that and not too
much and on yourself right as a person
because you don't have any traveler to
show so it helps you find a lot of
discipline and not falling into telling
your asourian and bragging about
yourself but again helping them focus on
the real project and go to a back today
[Music]